Top Gun maverick people have been asking
for sequel for years and years for 34
years people 34 years since I made and
everybody here yes and yeah in San Diego
that's right you flew you flew was at an
f-14 when you made tough gun yes and you
actually were in an f-14 for that movie
part of my deal was the Paramount wanted
me to make this movie for about a year
and I was shooting another film and I
came back and I met the producer Jerry
Bruckheimer Don Simpson you know he's
got the director and I I started working
with them and part of my deal was that I
had to fly in the f-14 they had to film
me flying in the f-14 and have it be
part of the movie right so I went
through all the pilot training and then
I filmed three I had three flights in
the f-14 in one day it was a dream of
mine I wanted to make movies as a little
kid yeah I wanted to fly airplanes right
and I wanted to make movies yeah so
right I was doing 203 so you so you have
like you finally you get you get to have
that experience and they push it to the
limit when you train when you're in
these planes you're experiencing the
g-forces that are the real pilots
experience and in the new Top Gun you
wanted actors that could handle those
conditions for real yes we part of
making this film is I wanted to really
be able to shoot a practical and we were
working with the Navy I mean incredible
pilots greatest fighter pilots in the
world and we wanted we had to figure out
how we're gonna get the cameras in there
we hired incredible actors great cast
brilliant and then but they also had to
be able to fly in the airplane so we had
to train them and actually test to see
can they sustain these kinds of G's
because some people can't fly this way
so we spent months and I tried to figure
out how do I train them to be fighter
pilots and then I had to take the
fighter pilots that were flying the
aircraft and really teach them about
cinematography editing and teach the
actors about editing and under
than about lighting because you're going
up to shoot and you'll see a little bit
of this you know if you're in an
airplane and you're doing your scene I'm
in my airplane but the lights and a
different angle I can't cut
I can't inter cut between the two of us
so I mean there's a law in convert there
took a lot to figure out how to do this
all kinds of amazing engineering to be
able to have the cameras be able to
sustain the eight G's that it needed to
sustain but from Top Gun to a film I did
called American made to fall out I'd
been really studying and I've done more
than just aerobatic and aerial sequences
and any other actor and so I really
tried to figure out how we could train
these guys up it's been important to you
that when movie when audiences sit in
the theater or however they experiences
that they feel that they have the
experience of being a fighter pilot yes
that's what I wanted I want them to have
that I look I'm here I'm here to
entertain you that's that's the
privilege of my job I love it I love
making all different kinds of movies and
with Top Gun I felt that one of the
things that we can deliver to an
audience is that kind of experience
right so when you're seeing the g-force
it's not a computer-generated image it's
actually the actors in there and they
care being the characters and you'll see
throughout I mean it's you know the
aerial footage is really beautiful it's
just I'm a pilot myself I love flying
and I love aviation so this is also it's
just a love letter to aviation the we're
about to to show the audience something
they're really going to enjoy but before
we do I think the two biggest questions
that are on everyone's mind is Kenny
Loggins song highway to the dangerzone
going to be reprise
and what's the other one yeah see ya the
other one is you know I when top gun
came out and it tell you it was the
story and what's happening but then I
would have to kill you you'd have to
kill me I would have to kill you I'm
it's a good way to go out I'd go out
that way I get to I'd get to tell people
in the afterlife I was killed by Tom
Cruise would make it an interesting
story no what I what I was singing is
that the other question is I've always
kind of wondered I think all of us you
know with Top Gun it was such a visceral
experience for anyone who was young and
watching that movie nicknames like
maverick goose these great Iceman what
would mine be if I was if I were to be
in a Top Gun movie what would my
nickname be Coco Coco Coco Coco Coco
Coco so you like Coco you got my view no
Hotel Coco Coco yeah on your six Coco
he's on your sake
poco tonight truck up can I have that as
a ringtone please
that's all I want in life is things from
myself oh man all right we'll go
we have you our cocoa I want you to just
randomly call me at different times
here's B what's that
oh gosh lazy lazy
oh poor lazy lazy how quickly does lazy
get killed in the movie like I'm lazy
goes right off maverick can't even see
I'm just done
Carrie just run my light off